you've met National Geographic Zeb Hogan
before um wild chronicles he combs the
world's waterways looking for the
biggest fish out there his theory is a
simple one the health of the world's
waterways can be gauged by the health of
its mega fish population if you still
have these giant fish species in the
river it's a good indication that the
river is healthy but most of these kinds
of big fish are endangered their numbers
have dropped dramatically in recent
years and that's bad news for the people
who count on the river for their
livelihoods and their dinner he's back
in Cambodia looking for the giant
stingray his first stop is the local
fish market
hey interesting right finding them here
means there's a decent chance
Zeb can find them out on the water so
this is a good sign we have a found a
small stingray the waters low it's clear
so we need to get out on the river
their first stop is the Coon Falls a
major fish migratory route and according
to local war home to one giant stingray
the largest stingray I've ever heard
about four hundred kilos almost a
thousand pounds with with Scott right in
this location just below the falls they
don't have any luck at the falls but
over the next few days working with
local fisherman zeb begins to get some
results so this is our first giant
freshwater stingray of the trip this
one's about four feet across 1.2 meters
and probably 70 or 80 pounds Zeb makes a
couple of quick captures but the rays
aren't the Giants he's heard about but
then we got a call about a big gray but
I don't buy it I don't believe it so
many folks start so many Ray's lost when
he goes to check out the spot he finds
more than he bargained for stingray this
sides giving birth before our eyes and
just a really cute little baby
the fisherman and Zeb gather around like
proud parents and it's big this is an
impressive rate of this raised probably
more than six feet long and then the
tail seven or eight feet long so the
total length of this fish certainly over
10 feet probably 12 or 13 feet long the
team gets their information and then
releases mom and baby
it's a hopeful sign one new member of
the declining class of fish not a giant
yet but hopefully this baby will have
time to grow
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium